i love mark wahlberg but at the rate
he's swinging it would take him three
[ __ ] days to draw that steel out hi
my name is neil kamimura i'm a
bladesmith blacksmith from hawaii my
business name is tikamimura blacksmith
it was established in 1932 hilo from my
great grandfather today we're going to
be looking at some blacksmithing scenes
and some forging scenes of some movies
and we're going to see how real they are
[Music]
robert downey jr has the best hammer
swing it looked like he had practiced he
was standing close to the anvil and he's
basically cold forging mild steel
so cold foraging is not using heat to
make it pliable like clay
like he's actually just hitting steel
cold i don't quite understand like
for one why the
he has the forge lit in the back since
he's cold forging it
[Music]
i don't know what he was doing because
it it the steel had no color to it he
was probably forging it at low heat just
kind of getting it to work but he's
cooling it off because it looks cool
they love the steam
[Laughter]
careful it looks like he's holding a cup
of tea
because
the crucible isn't hot
i personally don't think it would create
a perfect ring it would have to be
like a wax mold
that you cast from both sides with sand
it wouldn't just be pouring some hot tea
on it and it makes a perfect polished
electronic ready ring i would give this
a seven only because i like iron man
you know where you are
what you're made of oh boy this is the
one that i
absolutely hate the most it's not
because i don't like rambo i love rambo
but the problem is is that like for one
that's a real shop
that's
a shop that somebody's worked out of so
there was somebody in that vicinity that
knows what they're doing two sylvester
stallone
sells a rambo knife every release
and he has knife maker friends i'm
friends with jason mama i would never
let him do a forging scene like this in
a million years and he's using a
ball-peen hammer like out of a
mechanic's chest a ball being hammer is
a pound you know or maybe 12 ounces like
my hammer's four pounds
and i'm pretty sure he likes to lift
weights i don't know why he wouldn't
use a real hammer
what you're made of
see right there he just keeps
hitting it on the end
all he's doing is putting square hearty
holes
markings in the bottom of that thing so
here is your anvil right you have the
horn
so sexy right you got this horn you got
this nice curve on the back right and
then you have the center mass in the
middle
then there is a one inch square hearty
hole and that is meant for putting tools
in there you have to remember that the
steel is hot and you're just banging on
a square hole you'll flip it over and
you just have square hole marks all over
it i don't know why i don't tell him hey
buddy hit on the center of the anvil
like why are you keep hitting it over
the hole
when you're pushed
when you take steel at that temperature
and you quench it in water it micro
fractures 5160 should be quenched in oil
but it doesn't need to be quenched
because he's obviously not done forging
it and didn't make anything but a
pancake on the end of a leaf spring
two it's some magical water because he
quenches it in water and he lifts it up
and it's still hot
which that is also not realistic like
you put in water it would lose its heat
immediately maybe he just sucks at
forging so bad that it was so thick that
he didn't do anything to it so it still
held its heat i hold this to a higher
accountability is every rambo
movie he's forging how many rambos is
there like five rambos like
how has no one been like hey buddy you
absolutely suck you should not do those
scenes anymore or go take one lesson to
do it i give it a one rambo like i love
the movie i just don't like the forging
scenes
so the fact that he could take the
handle off with two taps of a hammer it
definitely wouldn't have survived battle
as you were hitting edge to edge but at
least they took the handle off on this
one some of them are pinned and a lot of
them are through and then the pommel is
what holds it on
but you definitely can't just take it
and be like
and then it comes off you know what i
mean
so when you're melting steel in like an
open-faced crucible like that they were
doing
one there wouldn't be just like orangey
flames like it would be
the most insane looking at the sun
that's one two
the actual crucible itself would need to
be hot that is just black
so it didn't heat up but yet somehow the
sword is melting on a black surface
which is the most
ridiculous thing ever
[Music]
swords that
were poured and casted like that were
bronze they weren't steel it takes about
3000 degrees to melt steel that kind of
steel bronze is a lower melting
temperature so that was a lot easier to
melt and cast but when they do cast it
it wasn't an open face on both sides was
it casted so that you pour it in the top
and it fills up and makes a perfect mold
the sword would look like a cookie on a
baking sheet you know so that's just
i don't quite understand
how they got
one sword and melted it and you somehow
made enough to make two
swords now you actually lose mass
as you melt steel like that i would
definitely give that a
four
the thing that i didn't like about this
scene is that they had it actually in a
cast
like in a mold
and he was breaking the mold out of it
there's many different techniques you
can cast an axe because
it's
generally not made out of very great
steel because it needs to take a lot of
abuse versus like a chef knife has to be
the highest quality of
carbon steel because it needs to be
razor sharp axes are brute
that force that needs to be tough versus
razor sharp
i've never seen a steel
butt forge weld like that in one hit and
it wasn't hot enough
and if you ever
put wood next to something that hot it
would disintegrate you don't hold it to
such a high accountability because it's
not real a tree dude is
giving his arm for a handle i mean you
can't
take it too seriously
i don't understand why he didn't just
cast it in one but there's no way he
could forge weld something like that six
i don't know
[Laughter]
for all his big muscles and i love mark
wahlberg but at the rate he's swinging
it would take him three
days to draw that steel out without any
breaks
like literally it would take him three
days at that hammer swing
it's the weakest swing i've
i mean it's pretty bad he loves the hole
too you see i'm hitting it on the hole
like you love they all love that hole
nobody wears a glove on their hammer
hand
ever because it's dangerous to hold the
hammer in that hand with a glove because
it would just fly out of your hand but
like if you are going to wear gloves in
a blacksmith shop they need to be a
glove that you can shake like this and
they fly off
because if you
once that leather gets so hot it will
cook your hand eternally within seconds
like you see people freak out and they
can't get the glove off it will like
cook your hand like an oven
are there things you just know how to do
right there you see generally you don't
quench finished forged blades that look
like
a road going up to a mountain that thing
curvy is crooked as can be once it
quenches like that
it's done
like you'll have to slowly take the word
like nobody ever would quench a crooked
blade
two he's only heating the tip
so like basically
he's heating this much
right here so only this part of the
blade would be hot this would all be
soft and it would catch a ban it would
catch a war traditionally in japanese
weapons
the blade is straight as forged
there's a clay on the back to prevent
the spine from getting hard so it
protects it from the heat and then only
the edge is exposed
the edge is getting hard and that's what
creates the natural curvature of a
samurai sword so you do not go in you
know bent and crooked for one and two
you don't forge the bend in it's
actually quenched and through the heat
treating process does the blade bend
this is the best part of all time where
he cuts his steel pipe
[Music]
[Laughter]
swords do not cut
pipe
people think that samurai swords are the
baddest things in the planet and they
are
for their time but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it was the
toughest and that it can cut through
cement and cut through no they were
actually some of them had a lot of mild
steel in them a lot of them caught bends
broke and i mean this movie is about him
doing it traditional right that's not
how japan traditional japanese
bladesmiths test the finished product
and they are a culture so based out of
respect you're not supposed to even
touch the steel with your hand they
would not take it and hit a pipe with it
it's just
it would be the ultimate disrespect for
them i'll give him
two
if you look at the first initial scene
there's one two three four five six
pieces of broken sword and then when
they go to put it back together it's
only two pieces so flux is it's like
borax so basically as it heats it's like
it's almost like melted glass that kind
of cleans it so that it allows it to
stick
together as you're forging something on
a flat surface and you're hitting it
with a hammer it would never maintain
that fuller and the fuller is that like
curved
uh
spot down the middle of the blade it's
on both sides so as you hit it it would
just flatten it out the correct way
to fix a broken blade like this would be
to take the handle and the guard off cut
it up into smaller pieces
add more material and forge weld it
again and forge a new blade if you want
to keep the same steel
you can just tell by their swing that
they've never touched a hammer in their
life and it's not nearly hot enough to
just butt weld the forged blade together
to forge weld it's at 2300 it's it's a
brighter color it's not orangey and
like it's white
six because they were actually forcing
air into a coal forge they were putting
flux on there to try and forge welded
so another once again another open face
mold and then he forges it i have
no idea what he's doing or what kind of
oil they put on there to make it do that
they're putting either grease or wax or
oil
and they're putting it on the hammer so
it creates this whole fire and but they
don't care about
whether or not the steel was actually
hot enough or where he's hitting it on
the anvil
look at this just the tip is hot look
and then we're gonna quench this sword
into snow
and lord so what happens is when you
take when you take a sword like this
and you quench it into oil
the reason why they move it up and down
as they're quenching it is because
what it does is it's so hot it creates a
vapor jacket that comes around it
and so it's boiling all around it so
it's vapor so you're not actually rapid
cooling it unless you're introducing it
into new
oil right so quenching it into snow it
would just instantly melt around it and
then not touch it at all
and i still sharpen
knives on a stone too maybe not a stone
like that but i mean they probably just
picked it up and was like you know i
don't know i would rate that a five just
because it was from the 80s and
they didn't know any better
[Music]
as she's hitting the anvil
she's like tap tap then hits the anvil
like you're not even swinging it that
hard you don't need to pump your brakes
it's the most ridiculous thing ever if
you ever see a video of me forging i'm
swinging a three to five pound hammer
and
yes sometimes when i move the blade i
have to keep my hand continuing to swing
i don't understand how she's engraving
with a nail
it's like a log cabin nail
so this right here is my forging stamp
it's done hot
and it's a
and it's pressed in i just hit it with a
hammer
yeah i give it a four
it wasn't hot enough
at all
like to forge well you know and that's
basically what they're trying to
replicate as as you're forging it and
you keep folding it it takes out the
impurities they're trying to hit it
and they can't even keep it on the anvil
but how they turn that little puck into
a half-inch thick
plate
with perfect square edges when they
swing a hammer like that
is beyond me and so why make a plate
that's bigger than the anvil
right you can't forge well look at it
it's just rocking on its own you only
want to open it so much to fold it
because how would you create enough even
pressure to forge weld that together you
would hit it here and then it would
forge weld here and then break loose
here you would hit it here you want
constant pressure of reduction
i would rate this a three i don't have a
favorite of any of them i don't think
movies in itself
have captured ever captured it it's just
annoying because it affects me they're
like all you do is pour the knife it's
not that hard and i'm like i swing a
hammer for a living i sacrifice my body
to swing a hammer they think i just pour
it in a mold you know so hopefully now
this gets enough exposure where they
might actually do a good one
[Laughter]
and if you enjoy this video you should
click right here to see the next video